exceptionnellement comme celui-ci c'est
le plus bas c'est pas dû à autre chose
que
il y a des scandales
ça aussi c'est vrai tu as raison c'est
vrai que tu arrêtes ça c'est compliqué
hein tu penses quoi tu penses que ça
joue le faire jouer beaucoup parce que
en fait non beaucoup de scandales se
sont mis il y a eu la légende de la
triche qui a été énorme ça c'est ce qu'a
fait le plus mal dans l'histoire ça ça
les amis par terre ça c'est clair et net
derrière l'avant-dernière saison bon
c'était moyen mais il y avait encore un
petit peu des scandales avec ce pauvre
François le pompier bon peu importe et
là la première s'habille tout le monde
par terre c'est c'est je pense que là
lui il les a c'est c'est le scandale qui
a fait du mal donnez-moi tu penses que
les gens il y a une solidarité avec les
femmes il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
doivent dire lui il est pas question que
je revois sa tête je vois les réseaux et
ça marque sa voix je la supporte plus
son comportement je supporte plus on y
en a pas fait un énorme buzz mine de
rien je trouve ça a été drôlement
étouffé quand même parce que moi je
trouve c'est un gros scandale il y a des
il y a des dommages collatéraux hein
allez pas demander à Charlotte et à
Jean-Luc son mari dans quel état ils
sont où Jean-Luc la femme se fait
insulter alors tu es incroyable et
Jean-Luc sa femme se fait insulter dans
la vie normale
allez demander à la jeune fille qui est
toujours en psychiatrie là depuis
juillet
c'est compliqué elle peut ils peuvent
même pas l'interviewer ils peuvent même
pas parler en tout cas toi Pascal dit la
vérité
moi je regarderai pas cause de ça il est
alors depuis quelques temps il s'avère
que moi j'ai fait 2016 à la télé j'avais
un mec en face de moi super humain très
discret pas de réseau sociaux il était
il était il était calme et on le
respectait aussi parce que il
intervenait pas on le voyait pas c'était
sur le jeu sinon on le voyait pas et en
2017 qu'en 2018 quand j'ai refait que le
deuxième Koh-Lanta c'était plus du tout
le même personnage il avait pris il
s'était étouffé il a évolué on a vu son
évolution en tant qu'animateur il prend
beaucoup de place et là ça reste que mon
mon nid que que ma vision il a pété les
boulons en 2018 il avait déjà pété les
boulons la tête elle est devenue comme
ça et ses comportements il les a déjà eu
quand même avec des joueurs avec
d'autres personnes donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'il arrive je vous dis la vérité quand
c'est arrivé il y a quelques semaines je
me suis dit enfin ça y est ça y
est ça sort comment il est mais soyons
honnêtes maintenant au tour de la table
n'est pas au courant de son comportement
alors je vais dire
Pascal moi ça fait très longtemps que je
l'ai pas vu Denis et je vais dire et
Denis il a été en amour avec moi parce
que c'est lui qui a fait la première
émission de l'amour à l'époque en 2012
c'est lui qui avait été accepté de faire
la première émission de TPMP donc
franchement j'étais comme un fou il
avait dit oui alors que personne n'avait
déjà vu l'émission sur France 4 donc je
me suis dit ce mec là est un amour et
c'est vrai que je l'ai recroisé deux
trois fois on s'est joué en tournoi de
tennis malheureusement il a perdu et
c'est vrai qu'il était énervé mais bon
ça je peux je peux comprendre ça je peux
comprendre
mais sinon sinon
et voilà à chaque fois que j'ai vu l'été
il perd sympathique j'ai pas vu depuis
on est quoi en 2022 je l'ai pas eu
depuis 8 ans voilà depuis 6 7 8 ans
voilà j'ai pas vu depuis non mais là où
tu dis pardon c'est pas pour mentir j'ai
jamais rencontré de ma vie donc quand tu
dis tout le monde savait euh je l'ai
vécu sur le jeu en fait c'est que c'est
pour toujours je reste dans mon analyse
et ce que j'ai vu et ce que j'ai qui est
vraiment vu c'est que où vous êtes un
physique un peu un peu qui prend de la
place et là il va pas s'affronter j'ai
eu le cas sur le l'orientation et la
reculé et mais après derrière il vous
punir après par contre on va pas rentrer
dans les détails ce qu'il a fait avec
moi on s'en fout je suis pas là pour
pour régler ça mais et avec les femmes
avec la femme entre guillemets là il a
un pouvoir par dessus et là il se laisse
aller quoi c'est la salut
tu as fait des coups
j'ai pas envie on dirait que je reviens
ici
c'est fait
des lives il veut pas parler je m'en
fous c'est pas grave c'est fini moi
c'est loin tout ça maintenant c'est
derrière Pascal j'adore mais j'ai pas
envie d'en parler
j'en ai rien à
oui j'étais tranquille parce que je m'en
fous
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas envie de revenir là-dessus
voilà j'ai rien non mais c'est vrai quoi
c'est vrai on passe Pascal non mais moi
je me rappelle du du de la fois que
j'étais chroniqueur juste avant de
rentrer ici il y avait des personnes
avec moi des chroniqueurs et tout et
tout le monde certains en ont parlé et
on avait ras-le-bol et ils sont là ils
sont là encore ce soir
qui sont certains sont là certains sont
plus là mais j'ai chopé la conversation
j'ai dit mais tu veux que Gilles Verdez
non j'étais pas là oh non tu n'étais pas
là
[Rires]
Pascal tu es la première fois c'était
lors de la viande du documentaire de
Marie bartolano c'est la première fois
qu'on a un peu évoqué ça mais de très
très loin sans citer sans citer
Charlotte
de passer ton temps
aussi vous vous le dites ou pas comment
entre anciens candidats de Koh-Lanta
donc c'est compliqué ouais il y a une
nuance quand même est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un de colérique avec un gros
caractère comme c'est que souvent le cas
dans le milieu et ça la rigueur ça va
être normal est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui harcèle vraiment c'est ça la
question qu'on se pose mais on peut pas
appeler du harcèlement c'est-à-dire que
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui
c'est où la punition ou alors il se
passe ce qui s'est passé avec Charlotte
et les autres personnes
regardez joueur qui va à ma saison
on peut pas être sérieux
je suis pas allé à la finale et d'autres
personnes on la finale devait être à
Paris et elle a été mis au cinéma Le
Grand Rex il y a Jérémy Javier plusieurs
joueurs quand il a su ça il s'en est
pris entre guillemets arabière il y a
mis plus bas que terre raviron a pleuré
ravir m'appelle me dit moi-même on le
met de Twitter il punit avec ses outils
c'est pas grave mais pour certains c'est
très lourd pour les joueurs de Koh-Lanta
c'est c'est ça frôle un peu une sexe on
est puni on a plus d'Oni Brogniart qui
vous suit on a plus Denis Brogniart qui
vous parle c'est c'est très lourd voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut mettre dans le
contexte Koh-Lanta c'est c'est vraiment
un monde à part on n'est pas comme
toutes les autres émissions je ne sais
pas